gus his way into you try not to ah
i want to say what is the lies spiral
over nothing
it's gonna be great on the blooper reel
you know you gotta give me a second
to undo this thing
we're done here you know what we are
done you'll deadbeat dark hanuman
peace out i can't remember that
tartan
[Music]
and you did that's john
[Music]
this close to being the drummer for aha
he's just a sweet retiree enjoying the
second chapter of his life
owning a sweet wardrobe
i mean over the bar
i mean there's a lot going on right here
i'm glad i'm not the only person who
doesn't know their lines
watch the problem solver solve a problem
once a problem solver solve a problem
you guys act like this is easy babe your
neck is way
out there on this one you know uh oh
everyone's okay everyone's alright
it was just traditional basic karate
that was just
well i'm going to see about a nurse
we haven't quite got all the elements
back in place yet
had it been season nine absolutely
uh your dad sweet over right stroke
addie he has a stroke
[Laughter]
this feels exceptionally bad
i'm like literally
was it like this when we when you uh
when scouting took
[Laughter]
[Music]
not place he's an only child
it is mine
all right we're looking good
[Music]
are you gonna say it yes i will
god sorry i made fun of you oh higher
like this is bad and that's in tim's
face and this is fine
nothing between this and that please
and perfect
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
good it's the most good it's the most
plains in north america
the busiest airport in the world
it's like overlapping flight school
see what you did there
lassie is that what i think it is
do to me this is
good this isn't good so we don't shut
down the airspace on site
that we don't shut down the esp
oh good oh sean gosh what are you guys
doing in santa barbara well
i left a signed autographed picture of
adrian's med when we moved and then come
back to collect it
well i left a decorative ceramic bowl
that said get in my billy
color me mine when i moved and i've come
back to collect it sean gus what are you
guys doing in santa barbara
well i left a signed headshot of swedish
pop star robin when i moved and
i've come back to collect it please have
a listen for me joel come here
just something i needed to do come here
come here
yeah i just scored okay he is he's
clearly doing it
yeah you ready
there's a lot of spit left out here yeah
so clean it out
just be really grossed out by it okay
i can make that real no no okay
okay okay get really mad and say
i hate you pants okay all right all
right
i hate you pants
i'm so mad at you belt we're not staring
we're gawking or as rucka howard would
say
is that renny harlan
who's norwegian nickelback is that mary
kate or
ashley olsen let's pray
he's my son such a cheese
that sounds fishy what did his face look
like when he told you that
um oh my god
oh my god
what did his face look like when he told
you that
oh my god do you guys suddenly feel like
you want to confess something
yeah i cried a little when big daddy
kane died in posse
yeah i sometimes root for the coyote
roadrunner's kind of an a-hole
probably didn't even cry when bradley
cooper beat his pants at the fake
grammys probably didn't even cry when
thanos killed gamora
[Music]
probably didn't even cry in a different
world season three
[Laughter]
delusions
come on man you know this drill find a
reason to
and we go and we do that i never watched
a show show
oh that makes sense that time what time
showing
oh will we find a reason to
then we go and we do them and he's
and we and then
commercial
you